[Music]
hello everyone I'm Pete also known as
now though just gonna give you a quick
little update review on Call of Cthulhu
it's a mystery kind of Clun based driven
game I'm not very far in about an hour
and 20 minutes only it's it seems really
good the graphics on it look really good
the interactions with all the people
look good you have skill levels that you
can upgrade and you can end up putting
points towards to kind of get your guy
stronger and that system actually works
really well I was able to lock pick
something and then once you go lock with
somebody else and I couldn't and it cost
me to get into a situation and then you
had to do a strength situation or a
cunning situation and if you felt that
you lost and then yeah it's a different
different way of doing things so it has
a lot of cause and effect which is kind
of really cool and D it has that
Resident Evil vibe one of the newer ones
like I think as Resident Evil 7 that
that was just came out that gamepad same
type of feel that you didn't know
exactly where you were going to be going
with it or what you were gonna be doing
with it and how you were gonna be
interacting and that that's the same way
and I'm not gonna lie there's there was
one scene that I actually got really
really spooked because I didn't know
what's gonna happen but it's gonna have
that fear in that scare factor which it
which is gonna be really nice it's gonna
be really interesting once I get started
no farther and further in the game as of
right now we're only you know we're only
an hour and 20 minutes in which is
really nothing
but I'm gonna keep pushing farther and
farther farther into the game every week
and see how it's gonna be and hopefully
towards the end again ends up giving out
finalized the statement on it
but as of right now this game it's
pretty pretty cool it's pretty pretty
nice little horror game nice little
scare game I'm liking it I hope that you
know you guys watch watch a little bit
of the the video I'm gonna leave the
whole entire first portion of the game
the first two full chapters on this
video if you guys want to take a look at
it and see it those cool parts I know
right now I'm over on top of myself and
I'll be disappearing in a second and I'm
doing this I'm gonna cut this before any
of the gameplay or I'm gonna cut it into
part of the gameplay for you guys to
take a look at it because I want you to
see it and I want you to see my
reactions to some of the stuff some of
the stuff is creepy but it's awesome so
I want you guys to hit that subscribe
button hit that button to follow us on
Twitch and hit that follow on Twitter so
you can see when we're going live you
can see when the guys go live on Sundays
for the iron Lords podcasts it's a great
gaming podcast it's for guys that love
gaming and they love to talk about it
and and I think you guys will really
enjoy it and and it may have got me
hooked and I try to be there every week
so thanks again everybody
have a fantastic time watching this
video if you got any questions or
comments and hit on that you know just
type them down below just type type type
down below and thanks again talk to you
guys later
good night everybody
I don't we thought the bolt-cutters here
yes
sentence controls you are
shoot left click
we got to interact with it
oh it interacts okay
now if people don't know me they know I
don't like scary games like this I don't
find this enjoyable or fun I tried to
get out of reviewing this game just
because out all those scary games
oh we can't go anywhere you got it this
way fantastic
look at the Steam with the graphics on
this
this is beautiful
to change Esther's
what the ask I wonder why I still take
these things
and spin it but why Merritt woman runs
off with her girlfriend
a good old story of black Natural
Sciences twistings archeology good
I wish ort the other way first oh well
since I shot it down
hmmm sanity
I hit spots hidden represent your
ability to find objects
the fluent those you church you are
speech strength
instigation psychology
dark water please I'm sorry
this will affect your destiny
[Music]
edie remove validate knowledge of human
behavior improving the skill nooses your
chances of understand the motives of a
person based on his or her behaviors
understanding past events by analyzing a
crime scene or an object at end of
picking locks terminating dosage of a
drug making a diagnosis expressing your
understanding of a medical problem
hmm
let's live them dangerous here huh let's
do point there point there
what's wrong work but are those cases
one coming
sir I came here on the advice of a
person whom I hold in high esteem and I
must say that I expected anything but a
drunkards lair you're free to leave
anytime sir do you know to whom you
speak
stephen webster industrialist and art
collector all of Boston knows tell me
mr. Pierce are you capable of handling
any case or are you simply a deadbeat
inebriate have you come to me means
nobody believes me they take me for an
old fool
Sara my little girl she is dead even you
must know her she was Sara Hawkins the
painter yes the police accuse her of
killing her family they all died in a
fire
Sara her husband and Simon my grandson I
can't do anything for a woman I was
already dead find out the truth they say
she was mad but I know that's a lie she
would never have done such a thing but
if you have no proof I've brought all
that I have
I want you to look carefully at this
painting tell me all the assumptions
that come to mind
what am I supposed to find tell me tell
me if this is the work of madness or if
on the contrary you manage to detect
some logic a rationality to follow so
that I may understand it is that all you
want from me yes please
all right look at you that's all you've
got the painting I placed a file on your
desk it contains everything I have on
the affair
new details and return attractors to
open a warehouse on dock where some
sketches of the Hawkins family rather
thin
this it's as if Sarah Hawkins breathed a
message in time so Mr Pearce what do you
make of these elements
investigation expert something's not
right with this story
I need to treat him I unlocked answer he
shouldn't of teens painting lately her
husband was a big deal on
though they mentioned serozha mental
state was fragile I believe you are
right sir this case is not as I am aware
of that I believe there is more to this
case than just an accident
you must tell me is what the police
suggest about the mental state of your
daughter
is true no Sarah had visions everyone
knew that she never would have heard a
fly she only thought she saw things saw
I never knew what she meant by that my
daughter was an enigmatic figure mr.
Pierce you must find out the truth about
her life and death
never heard of the place where is that
it's a small remote island off the coast
of Boston Sarah lived there with her son
and her husband I suppose you want to
[ __ ] me off there dark water holds the
secret regarding my daughter mr. Pierce
you must uncover it the meaning could be
exactly as it appears I think your
daughter is sending you a message that's
what I believe - it was three months ago
that I received the call from the police
telling me of her daughter's death and
yet a short while after this painting
was delivered to my home creepy painting
is linked to this case can't you see you
must find the meaning behind all this
the sender's label mentions warehouse 36
that's right
it came with Sarah's last painting and
you think your daughter could have been
the center that is what you must find
out go to dark water find warehouse 36
I think I'm beginning to understand I
like how it's forcing you to do all the
questions quiet that's something an
artist dies with her family in a house
where your only clue is a sort of from
on tree painting sent from before death
correct and the room is about her
supposed falling which you don't totally
deny find that warehouse find out the
truth regarding Sarah Hawkins death you
will be handsomely compensated huh
alright I'll take the case I'll go to
dark water thank you mr. Pierce I didn't
expect any less coming from the man in
your situation something's
dark water I think I've got a book on
the Northup oh my god
find some information on this I used to
be an avid reader the Wentworth agency
doesn't attract top-notch cases
I don't want to just leave without well
there is dark water is off the coast of
Boston but I've never heard of it
according to this all I have to do is go
to the port I just hope that I can find
a boat able to take dark water before I
go
interesting it gives you all information
automatically
hmm chapter 2 dark water port all right
we're gonna complete this one chapter
and then after that we're gonna be
calling it I'm will do a review offline
that will merge it with two everything
we need to do so it's very intriguing
this is actually cooler than I thought
it was gonna be graphics are really nice
looks like looks more like a Resident
Evil type of game which is kind of
interesting
you
you
entering the madness scary game no no
I'm done
looks really nice
yeah it does until I make my money green
screens come into problem
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stay on board there's guys coming to
unload
welcome to Dark Water Island mr. Pierce
why thank you
so what wind brought you does the
Hawkins case mean
like I said hopefully this chapters
quiet now what don't have a drink of the
stranded whale what you need is a good
pick me up Mitchell may not be very
welcoming but his bow holds a surprise
for you as for me you'll find me at the
harbormaster's office if it's the
Hawkins family that brings you here I
have a pile of documents that should
interest you understood look around the
docks okay talk to Fitzroy somebody
hey Sullivan the same goes for you sir
move along hmm it seemed to be very
agitated about a dead animal you're
telling me these fools think that
putting the whale back in the water will
bring about the end of the world they're
superstitious if only you knew they only
listen to captain Fitzroy and you what
brings you to our island I'm looking for
this address warehouse 36 dark water
harbor I like you so I'll be frank with
you don't go near the place don't try to
get in why because I told you so
learn to accept some friendly advice now
please allow me to do my job the blood
is just beginning to coagulate it died a
short time ago only a specialist
way to treat you can see that I'm busy
can't you you can't understand you're
not gonna shysters
[Music]
prohibition is just a joke around here
that suits me fine
let's noted
may objectives taught the Fitzroy
marriage I didn't screw the bar so we'll
go to the bar
Hey
let's get him another drink
in my bar we don't serve troublemakers
so that's some hole to test your shrink
you're overdoing it you saw what
happened he's the troublemaker no you're
a true mainland a real princess you
strut around with your la-dee-da ways
and then as soon as the pressure rises
you start squealing you don't have what
it takes to drink my whiskey we've got
to earn it I'm here for information I
prefer it that way speak then I reserve
the right to answer or not
do you know where this places warehouse
36 dark water the Hawkins warehouse I
see yeah if I were you I wouldn't hang
around there why not
first off there are rumors sailors from
around here say you can hear noises
coming from the warehouse at night
screams that's me screams and that's not
all there's the fate of its owners and
all the superstitions that go with it
but I'll say no more anything else
I didn't expect to find alcohol on this
island
what's the source of this milk you mean
who mm-hmm our source of supply wouldn't
like me to betray them to the first
comer
I'll tell nobody anyway anything else
mm-hmm
a stranded whale I guess this bar has
been here a long time well can I tell
you I'm a nostalgic sort of guy
the name it reminds us of the golden age
of dock water when our whalers left four
long months and came back sweating and
stinking of the oil and flesh and the
whales they do not hmm
it was a tough time all the same ah
steeped in glory we've never known such
wealth since then what can you tell me
about it we all knew she was famous on
the mainland for her paintings hmm never
understood why then I don't want to
speak ill of the Dead
that's speaking hell if it's true it's
true was it so terrible way I see the
truth is really a question of point of
view what do you mean by that do you
still trust the truth after a bottle of
whiskey her style made her famous how
would you describe it
torture yeah well it wasn't normal
I mean for a young woman with a child
and all that we saw them in the papers
and we said to ourselves who can paint
such things is that how she sees the
world so they made you feel
uncomfortable you need to see them for
yourself make up your own mind I've got
what I need anything else
captain Fitzroy told me about a little
pick-me-up oh yeah that must have been
before you came looking for a fight in
my bar oh come on
because of a little tussle drinking in
here is a privilege and I grant the
privilege to I don't want anything else
that'll be all for now okay
you like our song we may not be pros but
we give it all we've got
that's true it's a reminder of the time
when we were still fishing for whales
Darkwater
Island what brought whaling to an end
the whales of who's they all disappeared
you exhausted the stocks you could say
that yes there were fewer and fewer of
them until the last the biggest exactly
I've never heard this song before only
people from here know it it tells the
story of the miraculous catch it's a
local legend watch what you say young
man that can't save where's the proof
without the hole of dark water would
have died of hunger in 1847 it's true
everything happened just as it says in
the newspaper report what report the one
that's framed right behind you our
grandparents tasted its flesh it was
delicious I bid you farewell good night
stranger
nightmares can hear things and voices
whispering will follow its reader and
appear at various locations with its own
consciousness
the miraculous catch apparently the most
significant event of the last 80 years
there Charles Hawkins was a heavy
drinker and the debtor hmm interesting
over there what you looking at stranger
the clientele is predominantly tell me
something I don't know I meant I'm just
wondering what a woman like you is doing
in this flea trap and I'm wondering what
could be going through the head of the
chump who goes to disturb her let me
drink stranger I told you to beat it Oh
once you miss communicate with them
definitely changes your outcome okay
can't run that way
broken this place seems half abandoned
fishing equipment
salut the the toilet the paper a
souvenir from a more prosperous
I guess this blackboard hasn't been
wiped for more than 70 years asila many
stop beached at the entrance to the
harbor was it the Scylla a ship that
sailors with
so I wonder if there's a way to read
them
these are the doctor games you want
check it everything this man and fits
while I could be twins makes you wonder
if it is the same person
what a macabre a souvenir cartoon gun
appear
I brought out the Charles Hopkins cargo
manifests there on the table next to you
but in truth you're likely to be
disappointed when you're done
come join me on the deck
okay these manifests are signed by
Charles Hawkins
that's all wonderful access to look up
information on these you're not
I wonder what captain Fitzroy has got to
say about this that way let's go this
way
me sure
look Joe Oh for me I see everything that
goes on in the harbor the hard-working
lives of my sailors the fights of the
stranded whale even the antics of these
Wharf rats don't escape me it's you who
lays down the law around here oh I
wouldn't go that far
I'm just the last serving captain on
dock water tell me what I can do to help
you
unlock dancer talk about dark water
I found a threatening letter signed by a
circle cat what I don't mind you
visiting my hapa masters office but I'd
prefer if you didn't go through my
affairs are you being blackmailed
not exactly no that shyster wants to
make us pay protection money with any
success I wouldn't say that but she
terrifies my men as much as her own can
you not do anything to stop her don't
you worry about that the miraculous
catch is at a local legend not at all
it's an episode from our glorious past
go read the story of the sailors
returned to dark water Harbor it's
displayed on a wall of the stranded
whale I'm just back from the wharves but
that killer whale is unsettling the
sailors ah yes us men ever see are
superstitious folk
killer whales don't have many known
predators that's true
and normally they're not found here but
then you're gonna take me for a fool
give it a try have you heard about the
depths trenches that plunge it to the
earth and the shelter creatures unlike
any other you are talking about
mythology indeed you're right the police
took the decision to put the killer
whale back into the sea you've got to
understand them they didn't know what to
do with it I think that was a mistake
who says that whatever caused those
wounds is no longer in these waters you
think we should have kept it to look
into the real cause of its death
I was looking at your photograph one of
the man in front of the boat
ah yes I could see the one you're
talking about
interesting resemblance I thought it was
you but with a wooden leg and for good
reason
that's my father in the photograph your
father John Fitzroy
captain of the Silla his wooden leg is
here you can go and see if you're
interested
I'm looking for warehouse 36 you know
where it is
look it's right there the warehouse is
opposite the jetty you can't miss it
understood you know who the building
belongs to don't you
unlocked answers investigation expert
why it belonged to the Hawkins family
precisely humans from father to son I
think that somebody here wanted me to
search this warehouse your manifests
have been blacked out
they're totally unreadable yeah I saw
that I've got no idea who did it or why
I don't remember any countersigned
anything special enough for someone to
hide it and why obliterate the dates as
well as the goods stored in the
warehouse
you mean that the dates have some
meaning you tell me I'm surprised
Charles Hawkins had goods to store
knowing that whaling stopped in 1847 I
see that you're interested in the
history of our Island
indeed maritime activities ceased
altogether at the end of the last
century I imagine that the Hawkins
family had other types of contracts but
you don't know with whom you know it was
none of my business
I shall be on my way Casso come back and
see me when you've got something to see
[Music]
all right I think what we're gonna try
to do is we're going to try to push this
investigations go all the way so we need
six points
who's this dude where do you think
you're going
I thought the whole bunch talking most
that's true so what are you doing on
guard duty in front of this warehouse
who's asking the questions here the cop
or the tourists
what more can you say about the death of
the Hawkins family not much more than
what everyone knows I wasn't on a case
they were all burnt to death right hmm
up at their place
the whole mansion went up in flames
don't get it into your head to go
wandering around up there it's dangerous
what do you mean by that
the only one left there is old Silas and
the accident is affected him badly he
could be unpredictable especially if a
stranger starts poking around the
property is he a danger to the public no
he's in his own home do yourself a favor
leave him well alone you again I told
you to beat it no need to get worked up
yep once you do that question that you
don't want an answer to you can't
communicate with him anymore he says
can't talk
you live here Brandon yeah we'll teach
you to come onto our island and ridicule
our protectors I've never heard of this
site is it a local belief the Navigator
he's the patron saint of whales and
whalers what happened to the statue go
see for yourself
he's at the end of the jetty there's you
our beloved statue and then those two
bozos behind us yeah it's got to be them
there's one of them who's always going
back and forth to the statute what
brings you to dark water
the two guys behind you what are they
guarding they're protecting their
territory from whom I wonder you really
don't have a choice anyway and more
scared of cat than an attack by drunken
sailors if only they would kill each
other
is it cat who's shaking down nothing
peculiar house it's not because it
doesn't float anymore that we're going
to abandon it isn't it a bit early
Fitzroy gives us a futures every now and
again but since the whaling station shut
down ain't a lot of jobs left around
here so that statue represents I've
taken enough of your time okay so it
doesn't skip full conversations so on
the one look of dialogues would speak to
us a little more
no son dassera saying
st. Brendan hmm patron saint of sailors
and travelers desecrated I can't even
say which language is written hmm
interesting
can't walk with this
yeah
[Music]
somebody's stealing from the bootleggers
hello
I guess it's good answer that skill huh
the other thing is those two dudes in
the back
no idea what's with you wandering around
here like a hungry dog
we saw you talking to the two souks go
diet thirst a lot of you instinct less
I went to see the statue of Saint
Brendan what makes you think we did it
we're bootleggers not savages who do you
think they face the statue
what do I know they could have done it
by themselves
the sailors who else in your opinion and
who's interested so who are you
are you stupid doing it on purpose
everybody knows us on dock water I've
just arrived let's just say we're
standing guard for the owner of the site
and we let no one enter her property cap
she's your boss what you listen through
keyholes she's the boss yeah she says
who goes in or not shut up you dummy you
wanted to know that you also talk too
much she must be quite intimidating if
she can make two men like you tremble
she redid the smile at the last one who
wanted to get in I hope you had a good
dentist no no you don't understand
she really cut him a new smile but he
only smiles with left cheek
what are you guarding exactly listen
bonehead will she sounds fright she
doesn't like to be talked about behind
what will cats say when she finds out
that you've gotten to know that's true
apart from you didn't saw the way I
couldn't know that someone was gonna
forced a lot water to get into the hawk
that's all mm-hmm
move move I would let you
you can't go that way nothing there
once there
yeah this was super promising let's see
shoot I'll have to find another way to
get it huh it's no use
I don't give well well a little mouse
has got lost on our turf
you're not only inquisitive you're also
stupid
what gave you the crazy idea to come
onto my turf
your turf that's news to me for a guy
who has no idea you've been doing a fair
bit of poking around my men saw you
staking out the Hawkins warehouse is
that against the law I'm no idiot
detective I'll tell you how things work
around here I decide who comes in and
who stays out and anyone who doesn't
respect my rules I punish them is your
name cat what of it maybe we can come to
an understanding
maybe or maybe not
get this joker out of here he might have
a little trouble walking on his own
oh I'm getting careless I didn't see
that coming if I want to get into this
warehouse
how could you be dumb enough to leave
the entrance to the warehouses I'm good
keep your voice down why not go and
shout at the cat while you're at it I
don't want to end up with her little
knife under my mom
so there must be another way to get into
it
but the guys over here no longer there
either you saw what happened with those
sailors don't hang around here unless
you it's a little late well at least
you're still here something like that
with that please do excuse me
convene
Oh leave her a handle it must come from
these old winches
okay
a whale vertebra if the newspaper
clipping in the bar is true this bone is
a real fossil
mr. freakout this is something up there
I could use this old wind
can't leave
busted
and we are broken
oh please don't be the beginning this is
the beginning we're definitely gonna
stop for now this very interesting it's
uh almost like a mystery try figure out
what's going on
oh there we go I'm getting careless
I didn't see that coming if I want to
get into this warehouse so at least we
know if I wonder what would happen if we
knew about the I wish we know about that
you again like oh no need
you saw what happened when hey get some
what's up with that let's create that
information pick this up a hammer it
must come from these old winches it
looks like there's a way in well
vertebra a whale years old
if the newspaper clipping in the bar is
true this bone is possible
I could use this old winch to lift the
grading
however you said sir button for it
let's go down
ooh ratcheting erratic
okay
I'm messaging missing something else
just also beer
it should be possible to mount this
cogwheel okay all right now we got
everything
I got it now looks like everything is in
its place all I have to do is turn this
handle see
smokers come from the smoke
it's coming from this oil I hope it's
not toxic
nothing good is gonna come of this
that's crazy
this is primitive
oh this place stinks
what is the connection between this
place and the Sarah Hawkins case
what happened here
as this one Sarah Hawkins paintings
who has enough money to buy painkillers
can't sleep I know how that feels
and whoever it is has something to tell
me about
yo don't move you again I told you to
stay away from this warehouse it's just
son
see this is far from being wound up
someone else's interested can you
explain what I know it it was in the
Hawkins mansion when we came to
investigate the fine
so you confirmed that it was removed
from the crime scene hmm I'd like to go
and see the mansion of course you want
to go back along his trail I'd like to
understand how this painting made into
here come on my car's parked down the
way
this case has nothing to do with you
Baker clear the passage or I'll shut you
up for obstruction
officer Bradley you finally grown a pair
hmm too bad you're too fat to see them
down there why are you come on keep the
smile you don't want to force me to
widen it okay I get it
can we go to the mansion now I thought
I'd straightened you out mister I am
disappointed we'll meet again
is it fart this mansion
look behind you at the top of the ridge
you see the building
[Music]